es momento de hablar de nuestra revista
de prensa la actualización de los
titulares del mundo con rosa pero es más
de un rosa otra vez la salud
y en esta ocasión vamos a cambiar un
poco los temas vamos a comenzar hablando
de colombia y de la denuncia que hay
sobre las violaciones sistemáticas al
acuerdo de paz con la ex guerrilla de
las farc
eso es ayer la corte constitucional
emitió un fallo que el espectador esté
en medio colombiano considera una
decisión histórica dice la corte dio la
razón a ex combatientes de todo el país
que alegaban una falta de garantías de
seguridad en los territorios entre otros
incumplimientos al acuerdo por parte del
estado esto en el marco en que ha habido
270 ex combatientes asesinados desde la
firma de los acuerdos en 2016 ante lo
que el periódico dice la inacción del
estado lo que implica que muchos de
estos crímenes queden impunes y por
tanto la corte da la orden a las
autoridades colombianas de adoptar
programas de seguridad y protección de
los excombatientes para así facilitar
reincorporación a la vida civil y así
nos traía un tema muy polémico en perú
con el anuncio de pedro castillo de
posible referendo para que bolivia tenga
la salida al mar hablamos desde el
comercio de perú y ahora se suma otra
voz la razón de bolivia exacto dar la
razón a de bolivia en este caso destaca
que estas declaraciones como decías que
el presidente peruano hizo en el marco
de una entrevista en la cadena cnn sobre
que podría refrendar pues la petición de
bolivia de tener definitivamente acceso
al océano pacifico y destaca este medio
con este medio de bolivia no que el
presidente de la cámara del parlamento
boliviano saludó esta bienvenida esta
propuesta y dijo que sería profundizar
la democracia
y también tenemos esta noticia que ha
resonado mucho esta mañana aquí en
france24 sobre el uso de drogas entre
los camioneros mexicanos que no tienen
otra opción o por los recorridos tan
ardoz es que tienen que hacer un
reportaje de alexis a bus y eso es tal y
como comentan muchos de los camioneros
entrevistados en esta pieza de la cndh y
matan pues se ven abocados al uso de
drogas por las altas exigencias en
términos de productividad y las pocas
horas de sueño de las que disponen de
hecho uno de los testimonios asegura que
esta profesión era su sueño de la
infancia para así poder recorrer todo el
país y dice en mis primeros viajes me
quedaba despierto sin tomar drogas
miraba los carteles descubría lugares
paisajes e incluso tuve la oportunidad
de quedarme unos días en cancún hacer
turismo hasta que un día me quedé
dormido al volante fue entonces cuando
me decidí a tomar pastillas también
recalca como algunos jefes están al
corriente pues de la toma de drogas por
parte de los camioneros e incluso uno de
ellos explica cómo su jefe pago a la
policía para que lo soltaran cuando pues
las autoridades la fuerza lo arrestó con
drogas en el camión y bueno pues aquí
tenemos a muchos testigos de esta
problemática y de la facilidad con la
que se consiguen pues esto es
estupefacientes en las áreas de servicio
mexicanas estamos o muy mal en temas de
equidad de género y eso se debe en parte
a la falta de mujeres en los lugares
donde se toman las decisiones solamente
hay 17 de ellas en los gobiernos del
mundo así es es un análisis que hace el
diario punto es a raíz de la toma de
posesión de xiomara castró ayer como
presidentas de honduras y pues hace un
repaso y destaca que hay ocho mujeres al
frente de gobiernos en europa cuatro
mujeres africanas dos americanas como
decíamos pues al recientemente el
xiomara castró y por otro lado mía
mottley en barbados 2 en oceanía y una
en asia y recuerda este texto que el
hecho de que haya mujeres al frente de
los ejecutivos no implica necesariamente
que se adopten políticas que avancen en
la agenda de género y destaca que pues
las principales razones de esta
desigualdad
vidente después a los históricos
estereotipos roles de género y
desigualdades pues entre mujeres y
hombres y finalmente la nacionales
geográfica nos trae las mejores
fotografías de viaje del 2021
eso es nos propone aquí un recorrido a
lo largo y ancho del planeta que va pues
desde alaska a escocia pasando por
etiopía o emiratos árabes en los que
descubrimos un poco la gran riqueza
natural de paisajes y cultural de
nuestro planeta